the Trump administration is really good
at something now this might come as a
shock to you that I'm coming to you
today and telling you what they are
really good at the Trump administration
is excellent at what I call having oops
moments where they admit the thing that
they've made a concerted effort to deny
for a very long time so I'll give you
some examples when Donald Trump fired
James Comey we all knew it was to
interfere with the Russia investigation
everyone associated with Trump denied it
up and down came up with every absurd
explanation about why he did it and then
Trump was interviewed by Lester Holt and
he admitted oh yeah it was over the
Russia probe likewise
Donald Trump has been going out of his
way to avoid the obvious reality that
the guy he installed as acting Attorney
General after forcing Jeff Sessions out
Matthew Whitaker was installed
specifically to interfere with Robert
molars Russia investigation and in fact
Whittaker has this huge public record of
opposition to the investigation
he has written in a CNN op-ed exactly
what tactical approach he would take to
stop the investigation shortcut for you
starving it of funds but from Trump and
the people around him it's been deny
deny deny Trump saying he barely knows
Matthew Whitaker despite having met him
in person 12 times and then suddenly
over the weekend
Trump admits that actually yeah he did
put in Matthew Whitaker to deal with
Robert Mulder's Russia investigation
Trump was interviewed by the Daily
Caller
in a total joke of an interview this
interview had almost no follow-up about
any of the ridiculous things that Donald
Trump said and at one point Trump was
asked what were you thinking about when
you put in Whitaker what are your
thoughts about the installation of
Matthew Whitaker we're gonna put the
transcript of this up on the screen for
you look at how this goes the Daily
Caller says could you tell us where
you're thinking is currently on the
Attorney General position I know you're
happy with Matthew Whitaker do you have
any names chris Christie this means for
the eventual
full time or non temporary
acting Attorney General Trump says
Matthew Whitaker is a very respected man
he's very importantly he's respected
within the DOJ I heard he got a very
good decision I haven't seen it
Kellyanne did I hear that and then
Kellyanne Conway chimes in 20 pages
Trump says a 20-page Daily Caller
it just came out right before this sir
and then Trump says remember the
questions about Whitaker well I heard it
was a very strong opinion which is good
but Whitaker is just somebody who's very
respected respected I knew him only as
he print aend you know as he was with
Jeff Sessions and you know look as far
as I'm concerned this is an
investigation that should have never
been brought should have never been had
it's something that should have never
been brought it's an illegal
investigation and you know it's very
interesting because when you talk about
not senate-confirmed well molars not
senate-confirmed we've got to talk about
this piece by piece first of all nobody
mentioned the Russia probe in the
question and Trump out of the blue
mentions it except it's not really out
of the blue because it's the number one
thing that was on his mind when he
decided that Matthew Whitaker was going
to be acting Attorney General that he
believes the probe is illegal that's why
he appointed Whitaker so Trump very
publicly oops he connects the dots there
now I also don't want to do this again
because we did it last week but Trump is
lying that he doesn't know Whitaker he
only knows Whitaker through jeff
Sessions he said to Fox News last month
how much he knows Whitaker and he's met
with him many many times here's where we
really need to big-picture it a really
common tactic to distract people or to
confuse them is to change zoom okay and
what I mean by that is when people are
attacking you about details you switch
and zoom out to the big picture if
that's more advantageous for you it's a
debate technique it's a technique in
rhetoric when people are attacking you
about the big picture you zoom in and
you argue the details when there are
some details you feel you can defend in
this case the debate has been about the
details well how long was Sally
acting Attorney General does Whitaker
have to be senate-confirmed how well
does Trump know Whitaker gotta zoom out
and when you zoom out you realize that
if you're being investigated you
shouldn't be allowed to decide who is in
any positions that influence that
investigation period and that Pat is
what is missing from the discussion if
you understand that if you understand
that it doesn't matter whether Trump met
Whitaker to six or twelve times it
doesn't even really matter if Matthew
Whitaker wrote that op-ed explaining his
opposition to the probe although that
only makes this worse you shouldn't be
able to decide who oversees
investigations into what you've done and
that's why I think the left needs to
zoom out on this one Pat absolutely
absolutely and how fascinating is that
that Trump was able to commit another
unforced error here he's being
interviewed by the Daily Caller which is
a outlet that's supposed to be on his
side and yet he just volunteers this
information the term obstruction of
justice comes to mind that was floated
after he fired Comey it could get
brought up again and I think Muller will
look into that
these are obstructive interferences
whether they meet the legal standard of
obstruction of justice we're going to
have to see and by last thing on this
because there's just so much wrong with
it Muller is running an investigation
he's not in charge of a cabinet he's not
a cabinet level position he's just been
brought in to do an investigation he
doesn't need to be Senate confirmed for
that but he actually had been confirmed
by the Senate when he was director of
the FBI and that's another ruse and
canard that they are throwing at you one
of today's sponsors is Skillshare which
is an incredible online learning
community offering over 10,000 high
quality online courses on a huge variety
of topics first 500 who click the link
under this video will get two entire
months of totally free access to every
single class that Skillshare offers
you'll have free access to courses on
music art photography business computer
programming cooking meditation and
everything in between I think you'll
have no problem finding courses that are
perfect for you
just took a really great class on
graphic design which I know nothing
about but I'm trying to learn our show
is giving you two entire months of
totally free access to every course
Skillshare offers risk free if you click
the link under this video you'll have
two months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share that passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
10 bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up